what's going on guys this is Robin one
of the most requested videos I have from
you all is the character of gambit so I
figured why not make a video about his
character I mean it makes sense so
gambit first appears in uncanny x-men
annual number 14 in 1990 and was created
by Chris Claremont and Jim Lee now if
you recall our previous videos on the
x-man we had mentioned that during the
mid 70s and going into the 1980s the
team was being revamped and revitalized
by Chris Claremont as the writer for the
x-men proper now under Chris Claremont
Marvel saw an explosion and popularity
in the x-men which resulted in the
introduction of new mutants and almost
every turn now the point at which Chris
Claremont took on the x-men title with
giant-size x-men issue number one
leading up to the end of uncanny x-men
vol 1 is referred to as a claremont run
of the x-men but by 1990 Jim Lee had
come on board as a relatively new artist
and as well was leading into the release
of uncanny x-men vol 2 Jim Lee and Chris
Claremont introduced gambit prior to the
release of the second volume now we're
gamuts initial appearance in uncanny
x-men annual number fourteen is more of
a cameo his first real appearance came
with uncanny x-men number 266 now what
we find here is a gambit isn't actually
given a true origin story here in fact
his origin wyndcomm until 15 years after
his introduction instead he simply
appears as a burglar in the midst of
storm attempting to escape a villain
called The Shadow King now we're not
going to go very in-depth The Shadow
King here but suffice it to say I guess
he's basically a major villain and a
life of storm as well as the reason for
why Charles Xavier had traded the x-men
and the first place however the fact
remains here that due to gambits arrival
and the assistance of gambit and helping
the deep Howard Storm regain herself
gambit is eventually brought before
Charles Xavier and made a member of the
x-men
now the actual origin of gambit has
given to us in x-men origins gambit well
the problem with this story is that it
requires readers to have a decent
understanding of gambit himself and so
those who are completely unfamiliar with
the character of gambit were confused
when they initially picked up this comic
and so in order to keep you all from
feeling a little bit lost here what I'll
be doing is going through and I'll be
adding in or throwing in I guess the
necessary bits that will
you all make all I guess makes sense of
all of this stuff so the origin of
gamete picks up with gamete in New
Orleans as he's preparing to marry a
woman named belladonna of the Assassin's
Guild in New Orleans there are two main
guilds the first guild is the Assassin's
Guild followed by the Thieves Guild now
as you guys know I don't like using user
editable sources like Wikipedia and so
if I can't cite something in a comic
then I don't consider it to be absolute
or true with that in mind I'll leave it
to you all to decide whether or not this
little bit is true the accepted
information regarding the assassin and
the Thieves Guild is that Sandra is a
member of a race where a nearly immortal
race called the externals and that she
possesses a vast amount of power and
actually grants immortality to the thief
and Assassin's Guild by virtue of the
elixir of life now where this small
little bit right here isn't anything
that I would really refer to as being
absolutely true what we do know is being
true is that in gambit vol 3 issue
number 14
we're told that whatever gift Sandra
bestows on the assassin or the Thieves
Guild require payment by virtue of
tithing in order for these gifts to
continue and that should one of the
clans fail to provide an adequate tithe
then the gift is withheld until the debt
is paid now when I say tithe I don't
mean in the sense that she shows up or
and they basically give her ten dollars
or something like that tithing is
basically a word that's used to mean
that they have to fulfill a request from
her she'll basically say they need her
or they that they need to do something
for her if they fail to then that means
the tithe has not been fulfilled now
again I guess getting back in the main
origin itself what we find is that
gambit gives us the short flashback of
his childhood again as he's preparing to
marry belladonna here what we learn is
that when gambit was eight years old
that he stumbled upon a young girl being
attacked by several henchmen now when
gambit stepped in to assist in saving
the girl the two of them became fast
friends once the girl was saved and that
they actually ended up falling in love
with each other but the problem here was
that it was revealed that the girl was
actually the daughter of the leader of
the assassins guild and that because
gambit was a member of a thieves guild
that while they were in love while he
had this kind of Romeo and Juliet sort
of a relationship going on that
involvement between the two of them was
strictly prohibited and so what we
eventually find here
is that the leaders of the assassin and
the Thieves Guild aside that piece could
ultimately be brought about there two
guilds when they recognize the love
between between belladonna and gambit
and they realize that if belladonna and
gambit get married that it can unite the
guilds into a single clan making them
the most powerful clan and all of in all
of New Orleans and so this is what we
basically pick up with the origin story
we pick up with gambit as he's preparing
to get married to belladonna but the
problem here is that the marriage
between the two of them is interrupted
and actually halted it's never completed
because belladonna's brother shows up
and considers the intimate relations
between gambit and belladonna to be both
disrespectful to themselves
disrespectful to their clans and also
defiling the very honor of the
Assassin's Guild itself because again
belladonna is a member of the Assassin's
Guild and so what happens is that the
brother of belladonna in attempt to
regain what he considers to be the lost
honor of the Assassin's Guild challenges
gambit to a battle to the death
now gambit accepted the challenge but
during the conflict gambit uses powers
to ignite inanimate objects with energy
and killed belladonna's brother and so
the result was that the only way to keep
the gills from going to war with one
another was to have gambit basically
accept exile the reason being because
gambit had broken the traditional rules
of combat whereby the only way to fight
was to use the weapons that were
provided enough from here we jump to
gambit and listing the aid of mr.
sinister what we learn here is that when
gambit had first started to develop his
abilities that is to say when he was
around 15 years or so 15 years old or so
he found himself able to gain control of
his abilities quite readily at a pretty
fast pace but the problem was at his
time progressed gambit began to lose the
ability to control his powers and as a
result he basically sought out mr.
sinister to help him regain the ability
to control his to control his powers but
the bargain that was struck with mr.
sinister required something on behalf of
gambit himself and what we learn is that
in order for mr. sinister to assist
gambit and being able to regain control
of his powers that gambit would
basically have to gather a group
together called the Marauders now who
the Marauders are aren't explicitly
important to this story the only thing
that's really important here is that the
Marauders are basically a group of
henchmen that worked for mr. sinister
much like the x-men or the Avengers is a
general name given to a group of people
but what we find here
that gambit was basically tasked by
ministers mr. sinister to lead the
Marauders into the sewers of New York
but gambit hadn't actually been told why
it was this is happening he wasn't told
why was he was taking them there in
addition to this if you recall our video
about mr. sinister we had talked about
how sinister had believed that while
he'd been experimenting on various
humans throughout the course of his
existence that he believed that a lot of
these experiments had taken place in the
sewers of New York and that this group
which we know as the Morlocks were
deemed I guess to be non-existent or
they shouldn't have existed at the hands
of mr. sinister and this is why the
Marauders were assembled when gambit
takes the Marauders into the sewers
gambit realizes that the purpose of the
Marauders is to Massacre all the
Morlocks this is the event that's
referred to as the mutant Massacre or
the Morlock Massacre is really an
interchangeable term and it depends on
which one you want to use here but the
fact remains that once gambit realizes
what's going on he tries to stop the
Marauders but he's basically
incapacitated and almost left for dead
bye-bye Sabretooth and so as a result he
basically makes his escape but as he's
trying to get away he's basically I
guess caught by a more like woman she
appeals to him to get her child out of
there sir child can survive the Morlock
Massacre now following this origin story
and the eventual introduction into the
x-men proper his character became wildly
popular this was due to a couple reasons
the first was because he was an enigma
with regards to both the x-men and and
fan I guess comic book readers due to
being introduced to the comics without
an origin story
neither fans nor even the x-men
themselves had any idea what the history
of his character was and I would go as
far as to say Marvel probably didn't
have an idea of what his history was all
we knew was that the mystery coupled I
guess the mystery surrounding gambit
coupled with this devil-may-care
attitude basically made gambit an
extremely alluring character to x-men
fans now the second reason for why it
was a gambit became so popular was
because by the time x-men the animated
series the cartoon show came out gambit
was a mainstay in the x-men team and so
gambit alongside the other members of
the x-men the animated series cartoon
show basically received double the
promotion they were being promoted both
in the comic books and they were being
promoted on the TV show on the cartoon
show and so that's why those group of
individuals who are part of X
the animated series became the most
popular members of the x-men team over
the course of the life of the x-men
universe now if you recall our video on
x-factor we had talked about how the
x-factor line of comics came into
existence when Cyclops had left the team
after the presumed death of Jean Grey
and the arrival of Madeline Pryor now
once Cyclops had returned to the x-men
along with the original x-factor team
and the real Jean Grey character the
x-men group was split into two teams the
first team was the blue team which was
composed of Cyclops Wolverine Psylocke
row gambit beast and Jubilee with the
Gold team consisting of storm Jean Grey
Colossus Archangel Iceman and Bishop now
the reason why I bring this up is
because it was during this time when
Marvel started to basically be least hit
bits of gambits backstory and one of the
most prominent hit bits that was given
to us was his involvement in the mutant
massacre now again at this time in the
story of Marvel Comics I guess in the
chronological history of gambit we
didn't know that he was part of the
mutant massacre we simply just knew that
the mutant Massacre had occurred but
what had happened here is that with the
with the revelation that gambit had
basically led the led the Marauders into
the tunnels where the Morlocks were
killed because of the presumed belief
that gambit had been the helping hand or
I guess the hidden hand behind this
whole mutant Massacre
while gambit had had an established
albeit non physical relationship with
rogue as well as having a strong place
within the ranks of the x-men lineup
this was basically all torn asunder that
gambit was banished from the x-men team
proper and that his relationship with
rogue was basically severed entirely and
so going into the 2000s following
gambits outcasts from the x-men in truth
his character never really recovered and
many fans consider his casting out to be
the death of his character almost in its
entirety over the course of several
issues and even several attempts at a
solo series basically trying to bring
gambit back into popularity what we
found was that gambit basically kind of
went to this free fall through some of
the worst parts of the world he had all
these different employers and things
like that but it just never really
resonated with fans the same way that he
had previously done with his initial
introduction into the x-men and so for a
lot of people they looked at gambit once
he had rejoined the x-men
as just another x-man he really wasn't
anything as stellar as he had previously
been but the fact remains that even
considering this considering the fact
that gambit has sort of lost his a lure
losses intrigue he's still a very
popular character among a lot of x-men
fans in fact some x-men fans I would say
most x-men fans would look at classic
gambit that is to say Buganda before he
was cast out of the x-men as being the
best version of gamma being the one true
version of gambit with all the other
ones being poor attempts by Marvel to
recapture what it was that made it
popular in the first place but that
being said we're going to go ahead and
bring this video to an Ana hope you guys
enjoyed it if you did let me know and I
will catch you guys later peace